CS2 will soon replace CS go and although
it's sad I know that it means we're
going to get years and years of new
updates Maps operations and God knows
what else but even considering all of
that I can't get one question out of my
head is valve ever going to give us a
new gun
okay before we go down the rabbit hole
of a potential new gun in CS2 I gotta
talk to you guys about our latest series
into the dark we partnered up with our
friends over at Kraken rum to tell you
guys some of our favorite stories
involving Esports most iconic Risk
Takers it covers a wide range of scenes
including CS so make sure you check out
the link in the description if you want
to see more alright so ever since CS2
was officially announced data miners
have uncovered some crazy hidden within
the Game's new code but while much of
the community awaits new knives skins
and made Koozies I have become
preoccupied with another a potential new
gun now we'll get into whether or not
Counter-Strike 2 actually needs a new
gun very soon but it's important to know
that it's been a very long time
Counter-Strike hasn't received a new
weapon since the R8 infamously dropped
in the winter 2015 update now before
anyone brings up the MP5 SD that is not
a new gun in my opinion that does not
count the MP5 has always been in the
game this was just them bringing it back
in a update Midway regardless it's been
a long time since Counter-Strike
received a new firearm or even piece of
utility sure random crap always gets
added to Danger Zone but nothing in
standard matchmaking so the question is
does CS2 need a new weapon and if so
what does that even look like well we
could spend all day going through Gabe
followers Twitter to find conspiracies
of a rocket launcher finally coming to
Counter-Strike but since valve loves
putting things in their code that never
see the light of day I'll believe it
when I see it so for now let's talk
about what it would actually mean for
Counter-Strike to get a new weapon and
let's get the obvious out of the way
making a new gun in Counter-Strike is no
easy task as much as we all love
watching those creators who add and test
out new wild guns it's obviously not
that easy Counter-Strike is a carefully
balanced tax shooter and even adding a
single gun or piece of utility will
disrupt the dynamic of the game in a
very big way I mean with the switch to
mr12 valve is already going to have to
make changes to the game's economy an
entirely new weapon is going to add even
more variables especially if it's a
rifle now just because it's a difficult
process doesn't mean valve shouldn't do
it I mean the money they'd make off of
skins alone would be well worth the
effort it's a money printing machine but
money isn't everything in this case
adding a new weapon would actually help
CS2 compete with valorant in a more
direct way Valerian has the luxury of
being a hero shooter so on top of maps
and skins Riot gets to add new
characters with new abilities that gives
people a reason to come back to the game
and they can do that basically whenever
they want now obviously valve can't
release guns as often as Riot releases
agents but even if we get one new weapon
in the next five years it's a pretty
massive addition for a series known for
its moderation what I mean is outside of
everything that's coming to CS2 valve
doesn't really do big grandiose changes
they don't even really like doing small
ones and sure we don't need a new gun by
any means the current roster is one of
the most iconic in the history of game
aiming but maybe that's why people like
me actually want a new gun in the first
place adding a new gun would be even
bigger than adding a new map it would
change the DNA of the game forever valve
adding a new gun wouldn't just bring
people back to try it out it would
create Buzz start conversations create a
cult following of people that only use
the new weapon in CS2 it would change
everything does that mean that valve is
going to do it no not necessarily but
some people seem convinced ever since
valve made the massive change to cs2's
Loadout tons of community members came
under the impression that it was
actually their sneaky way of making room
for new additions to the Arsenal since
you could now hot swap weapons why not
add even more now while I do see the
logic there I think it's a bit of a
stretch there's a ton of new Cosmetics
coming and I think this was valve's way
of just adding a UI update that being
said it does give me just enough
evidence to talk about what cs2's new
gun could be now I know I'm not alone in
this reasoning but I think there is only
one option that makes sense a t-sided
semi-automatic rifle that operates very
much like valerian's guardian and it
sits in between the AK-47 and the glial
so wire rifle well it's kind of the only
one that fits right now counter-strike's
pistols pretty much hit all the spots
and although I thought about something
like a shorty adding Azusa on steroids
would probably be a bad idea on top of
that no one really uses shotguns or lmgs
and when it comes to SMGs honestly
speaking there already might be too many
so to me a rifle seems like the best fit
and making it semi-automatic will make
it different enough from the Galil and
the AK and dollar has taken so many
things from Counter-Strike I think we
should get something in return now as I
mentioned I do believe a gun like this
would only be suited for the T side
because in my head while having a low
rate of fire it still provides One-Shot
headshots from most ranges and while
damage drop off can be played around
with to help balance it in between the
other two t rifles having an accurate
One-Shot headshot rifle on CT side is
just not possible if they really wanted
to they could technically add two
weapons like this and one of them just
has a much lower damage output but since
the CTS already have access to the a1s
and A4 and the t's have just the AK I
don't really think it's necessary I
don't know about you guys I've seen it
online but I really love this idea but
for fairness I've been trying to think
about a reason outside of balancing why
valve wouldn't go for something like
this and I can only really think of one
the AK-47 and its One Tap potential is
one of the most iconic parts of not just
Counter-Strike but gaming in general and
adding a gun that is basically built to
do that exact thing could take away from
its Mythos it may seem silly but I think
there's a very deliberate reason why the
R8 is dog in comparison to the deagle
that being said I'm still hopeful the AK
will always be the AK to me and adding a
FN foul or an SKS won't take away from
its ability to both top heads and spray
multiple people down but that is just my
opinion listen we are on the doorstep of
a new era of Counter-Strike and valve is
open to pretty much adding whatever they
want it doesn't even have to be a gun
that being said I would love to see a
new rifle in the game and I'm curious
what you guys think is there a gun or
piece of utility or item you want to see
in the game or are you one of those CS
purists who hate anything new and
anything fun
let me know
valve whenever they do something new
with their games they always like to
like add a new feature that shows off
what they're able to do with like their
new physics or lighting engines and
obviously like the big one is like the
smoke grenades so the question is like
will valve add something to the game
that has like more to do to play around
with the smokes you know what they
should add the cipher Trip Mine that
would instantly ruin the game and they
should add it or a cipher can yes add
Cipher to the game and people just be on
their phones the whole game